oh well next game was Grandmaster far
gone from Russia no idea who this is um
interesting yeah I wanted to wide there
be no name now we get some interesting
position it's a little bit like a right
eye opening with reversed colors
I just have one extra tempo of course
and try to hang on to the porn it's
actually not that easy to get the porn
back I think it's basically not possible
to get it back black needs to find some
ways to get compensation
it's actually rather high rated 2500
okay there we go yeah I need to take
know what what is he doing if I if I
take the second porn I'm not sure
there's some brilliant trick I don't see
it he needs to show me I think
okay for just just go back now
I need to get some development going of
course
maybe you can sacrifice on c3 yeah yeah
okay but I'm not I'm not forced to take
it at the moment I think I've at night
before is coming yeah okay I need to
take so now what if i play Bishop d2
right be4 can take C 3
so let's take a quick a quick count of
the pieces it's good five points I've
got two pieces for rook but you might
take here so we get another poem
I cannot really cover this I think
so
okay this one is hanging we should be
phone maybe come to take on c5
I don't want to take their to exchange
Queens don't think this would be would
be good but what can I do
another idea would be straight straight
forward at tackle Queen h6 look a 195
this looks good but you can just play
notes no to e6 mmm really complicated
position I need to get this piece into
the game even if it takes a 2 e 2 at the
end for instance take take take on it to
the 95 maybe I need to get some activity
black forfeits due to disconnection oh
you disconnected well thanks for the
points but I really would have liked to
know what was going on in the position
okay I do a computer check he's just
saying equal like usual it wants to take
on b3 queen bee three and now Quincy to
this one I guess is really bad because
of 95 here I got the double this one
right now it wants to play Quincy to
with an equal position after exchanging
and Bishop deform interesting yeah it
was completely unclear game just as a
quick quick check he's got a name in
there no name okay
yeah interesting game nevertheless